what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest events into
seven that Lisa in series including the
dark side of chaos power a power that
has the potential to do an incredible
amount of good and a power that also has
the potential to turn all of Britannia
into a living nightmare merlin appears
to have a secret plan that goes there
may know about Arthur's old friend
returns for another friendly visit and
the entire world could be in existential
danger once again so basically it's just
another casual Saturday in the world of
the seven deadly sins so let's get into
it if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
videos on this channel you want us to
keep it go and please leave a like to
let me know it really does help and if
you happen to be new to anime pro please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible we've been
getting more and more patron support
lately and it really means a lot when
you look at all the problems facing
YouTube on a daily basis so thank you
guys so much more about our patreon at
the end of the video but now please
remember that this video will contain
seven deadly sins manga spoilers we're
dealing with the latest developments in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the official
translation chapter 340 is called I miss
you and it begins as the sins in
Elizabeth suddenly find themselves back
in the onus everyone there is surprised
to see them including the King Elaine
and all the others but when I say the
sins are back in the onus I am of course
not including our boy
Big Daddy sunshine who is still dearly
missed and I am not counting Merlin who
decided to stay behind with Arthur the
rest of the sins are wondering about
Merlin and why she decided to stay alone
with Arthur something that she must be
distraught but meliodas thinks that
Merlin might actually be pleased with
the way things are going I assume that
what he means here is that Merlin is
happy that she gets to study the
mysterious power of chaos after all this
time and indeed when the chapter shifts
back to Merlin she does appear quite
pleased
Arthur is resting inside one of the
castles that his mind
subconsciously created due to the power
of chaos while the sword Excalibur
appears to be constantly changing its
shape the sword seems to have dozens of
little wings on it some are white and
angelic and others are dark and bat like
Merlin wonders whether this is the
swords original form or whether the
sword is still unstable and is
continuing to change because Arthur's
magic has not yet fully formed Merlin is
highly intrigued by the power of chaos
and by Excalibur and when he wakes up
Arthur remarks that he hasn't seen her
like this in a very long time this is
the Merlin that he's always known
inquisitive curious and excited about
magical knowledge eventually Arthur asks
Merlin why she never told the rest of
the sins about the power of chaos Arthur
is wondering why Merlin would wait until
now to tell them instead of being
straightforward with her friends from
the very beginning but instead of
answering directly Merlin asks Arthur
whether he hates her for resurrecting
him as the king of chaos in the name of
her own curiosity and ambition Arthur of
course doesn't hate Merlin and he says
that this power is a great opportunity
the power of chaos is both a darkness
that even the demons fear and a light
that even the goddesses Revere at the
same time the power of chaos also allows
its master to create amazing things and
defy the laws of the physical world this
means that as long as the power of chaos
is wielded by a person with a good heart
there is unlimited potential for that
person to do great things things that
will help people who need it the most
and make the world a better place as
Arthur says this and as we see images of
a happy world where people are dancing
singing and enjoying themselves the dark
wings on Excalibur disappear and only
the white angelic wings remain this is
very significant and I will talk about
it a bit later on in this video
back in Leonys the remaining sins are
still talking about Merlin and the
current situation and melly Otis wonders
whether he ever really knew a thing
about Merlin despite having known her
for so long the seven deadly sins as a
group seemed to be a thing of the past
after all
ESCA noir is gone and Merlin has
abandoned the sins so their little group
can never
be the same again King seems to think
that Arthur will be fine now that he's
managed to defeat Kath and now that he
has Merlin watching over him again but
meliodas warns of them that chaos is not
gone yet malli otis reminds the sins how
incredible the power of chaos was and
how arthur was just creating things and
changing the world around them without
even being aware of it if at any time
Arthur cannot exercise complete control
over the power of chaos if at any time
he slips up or something happens to him
that makes him emotional or unstable
just like all those wings turned white
when he was feeling good and
kind-hearted all those wings might turn
dark if he is consumed by darkness
so Arthur could unwittingly unleash the
darkest and most dangerous aspects of
the power of chaos upon the entire world
meliora says that if the power of chaos
ever gets out of control
britannia could become a living hell
chaos could destroy all of Britannia and
turn it into a waking nightmare just
like the demon king could have done if
he had not been defeated chaos might be
even more dangerous than the demon king
because Mele Otis knew the demon king
well the demon king was his father and
he was a member of the same demon race
as him so Mele Otis had a very good idea
of what the demon king was capable of
and what the true nature of his power
was but with chaos things are completely
different this power is a mystery it is
unpredictable and it is different from
anything that they had seen before when
DN asks why Merlin stayed quiet about
the power of chaos all of this time and
only told her friends about it now Mele
Otis says that that is a good question
and that they'll never know unless they
ask her for themselves but go thir then
steps in and asks the rest of the sins
whether they really don't know the
answer to that implying that he may
actually know the answer the next page
of the chapter takes the story back to
Merlin and Arthur so we don't actually
learn what Gotha was going to say but I
wonder whether what he was going to say
is related to his creator
the original gopher after all the
original Gotha was the one who trained
Merlin and helped her master her magic
and the original Gotha was also the one
who sacrificed his own life in order to
end the holy war
or from 3,000 years ago I wonder if
Merlin made some kind of deal with
Goethe er a deal that involves using the
power of chaos to prevent the holy war
from ever happening again
perhaps Merlin will use the power of
chaos to separate the different realms
from each other permanently thereby
altering reality in a way that fulfills
the prophecy that is mentioned in the
intro of the anime an intro which you
may recall states that this is a story
from ancient times a time when the human
realm and the non human realm had not
yet split this implies that at some
point in the future they will split
which would make all future holy wars
between different races impossible and
so the reason that they are going to
split in the first place may be none
other than the power of chaos back in
Arthur's chaotic castle Arthur voices a
desire to return to Camelot but before
Merlin can properly answer him some sort
of strange rumbling occurs an ominous
voice calls out to Arthur from outside
the castle saying that it knows that
Arthur is here because it can smell him
and it is such a delicious smell it is
then revealed that the owner of this
voice is none other than calf itself
Kath was not destroyed by Excalibur
instead Kath has seemingly obtained a
new even bigger form and I have to say
that in this form Kath looks a lot
cooler and more menacing than the
previous one this is an evil cat villain
that a culture dweeb like myself can
actually respect the giant calf has
climbed up the castle turret within
which Merlin and Arthur are located and
it is trying to find its way to Arthur
in order to devour him but instead of
Arthur Merlin emerges from the castle
and tells Cass that she will be its
playmate Merlin then uses her magic
including her sacred treasure the
Morningstar wall then to deliver the
first blow of the fight and it is a
direct hit on the face of the new and
improved calf the text on the final page
implies that Merlin is putting her life
on the line to protect Arthur which
suggests that Kath may turn out to be a
more powerful opponent than we realized
especially if it is now strong enough to
threaten Merlin's life personally I'm
glad that cath didn't die so easily
in the last chapter it seemed as if Kath
was destroyed by a single blow from
Excalibur but if that were the case then
this whole CAF twist would have been
completely meaningless learning that
this creature which has been around for
a very long time in which we thought was
Arthur's friend was actually a villain
trying to devour Arthur was definitely
interesting but I thought that after
this big reveal his easy defeat was
disappointing and anticlimactic with
that in mind I am actually glad that
defeating Kath wasn't that easy for
Arthur however the whole CAF thing will
still be pretty meaningless unless it
turns out that there is some bigger
connection between CAF and the overall
story so for example maybe there is a
connection between Cass and the supreme
deity as I speculated in previous videos
if that is the case then the CAF twist
this late and the story would make sense
but if Kath is a completely random and
independent villain then the whole thing
seems kind of unnecessary in that case
they could have just used any monster
villain to come and try to devour Arthur
why make Kath Arthur's pet in the first
place all in all this whole current
point in the story the whole chaos arc
really needs more direction in my
opinion I feel like we are all a bit
confused about what exactly is happening
and where exactly the story will go from
here including the main characters
themselves
they all look pretty confused too there
are too many unknowns at this point from
Merlin's true motivations and goals
cryptic statement about Marilyn's true
intentions to the Lady of the lakes role
in the story and casts connection to the
wider plot I feel like we need more
guidance right now we need some sort of
information about what exactly Merlyn is
planning where Kath came from who the
next major villain is and so on without
this additional context the current arc
feels a bit disjointed we had the epic
fight against the demon king we had
esken or sacrifice and then after that
reached its conclusion we are just kind
of moving along from mystery to mystery
without a clear goal or purpose in sight
I do believe that naka bouzouki is going
somewhere with this and I'm sure that it
will all make sense and come together in
the end but we definitely need more
direction we need more context we need
more answers and unless we get them soon
more and more people are going to
complain about the story feeling dread
out although to be fair no matter what
knock about does somebody is going to
find some reason to complain that is the
case with every Monica it's just a
matter of how many people are
complaining for what they believe to be
legitimate grievances and how many
people are complaining just to complain
personally I do want to give knockabout
the benefit of the doubt because so many
of the recent arcs were absolute fire
but I do think that we really need more
guidance and more answers at this point
who is the next major villain is it Kath
or is Kath just a warm-up for someone
else
what is Merlin up to is she about to
separate all the realms using the power
of chaos or is something else going on
why was Merlin so desperate to attain
this strange power of chaos was it
really just curiosity or is she tried to
fulfill the legacy of her former master
the original goal her by using chaos to
ended the holy wars once and for all
feel free to hit me up with your take
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more videos like it please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications if you
don't go through the trouble of clicking
the bell and then turning on all
notifications you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos
it's just how YouTube works I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support our content
and make these videos possible first up
let me thank our the one tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola nod of
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson query know I also can't
forget our awesome pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress very dolla beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's key on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy E
vodkas Jean d'Arc
and Joe Stanton if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our page and exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
cherry people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us spanks Cowboys
[Music]